when you ally people's desires  with the corporate pharmaceutical  promotion  to physicians and the public then you  have  forces that almost no one can resist  so but how did it all happen these are  many many trends converging from the  anticipation of  women to the medicalization and the loss  of say religious influences to the  dissolution of large extended families  to all kinds of social factors play into  the fact that we are now  feel responsible turning ourselves into  these  neurochemical sensors out there  that's all we are that's how you know  the promotion is that  we are these neurochemical units that  require adjustment by experts who know  better